in tunisia do people go like hunting for
their food
yeah uh yeah some people yeah
it's almost turkey season we should take
him
he'd love that i'd go i'd go turkey
honey
insecurities will play tricks on your
mind
and have you seen things that aren't
really happening
rebecca and ziad went out to dinner with
her daughter tiffany and some friends
and tiffany's friend hannah became a
problem
especially after she offered up her
family's trucks to help zia move his
stuff
you're gonna let her help you move you
she is offering to help you move the
furniture
oh no thank you oh no you don't need it
thank you ugh that green eyed monster
can be a beast
we're gonna talk about it plus mike and
natalie wants a couple's therapy
and he told her that he's no longer in
love with her
shocker i mean after all they've been
through how could he be
you want me to go home
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
as you could see mike is definitely over
it
and next week things are going to get
worse after natalie insults him
once again it's funny because i'm much
beautiful than you
your beauty is ugly oh teller mike
that was nasty before we get into their
situation which we know is going to
end in disaster let's talk about rebecca
filling insecure is a terrible feeling
no one wants to feel it yet we all have
because we're what
human rebecca tried to hold it in
but insecurities about her age caused
her to get extremely
jealous that our daughter's young hot
friend hannah
was showing ziad any amount of attention
so so far what's like the biggest
difference that you see
in america to where you're from so in
tunisia
do people go like hunting for their food
yeah
uh yeah some people yeah you know ziad
he's a really friendly guy he can talk
to anyone
but this young hot girl seems way
overly focused on him
i noticed that i'm the only one at the
table my age group
and i understand i know i signed up for
this
but in reality it makes me uncomfortable
at least she was honest
about what she was feeling some people
can't even admit that
at the same time insecurities have a
unique way
of skewing your vision because based off
of what i saw
i didn't think hannah was overly focused
on zead at
all everyone at the table is from canton
georgia
canton georgia so of course the man
fresh from tunisia
is gonna get the most attention right
now the only thing we have in the
apartment is the mattress
so possibly while i'm working he can
get all the stuff out of the storage
unit moving into the apartment my family
has lots of trucks
so if you need like a truck bed
i'd love to help yeah i got a good job
that's so nice hannah thanks
[Music]
you're gonna let her help you move what
you're gonna let her help you move ew
she is offering to help you move the
furniture
oh no thank you oh no you don't need it
thank you that was awkward
but rebecca you're not alone girl if i'm
to be honest
i've been there before too and if you
don't remember
zead has also struggled with jealousy
issues in their relationship
when rebecca was in tunisia he went off
on his friend for looking
at her too hard so i think he recognized
that looking rebecca's eyes at the table
and got it together real quick it seems
like my mom is just really insecure
about
the fact that a pretty woman is trying
to help ziet and hannah's not meaning to
be disrespectful whatsoever
hannah's just trying to be genuinely
helpful i'm not trying to step on any
toes here i just
seems like you guys could use maybe
another set of wheels
i appreciate that
i think we're going to head out yeah it
was nice to meet you
thank you thank you welcome to america
thank you
bye bye
bye yeah they're definitely going
to have to work on that you know there's
something else
that i thought about rebecca's daughter
tiffany and her fiance micah
like to put ziad through test for all we
know
this could have been part of their plan
to bring a young
hot attractive woman to dinner to see
how ziad would react
it might be a reach but hey you never
know
alright big mike and natalie these two
have been fighting all season
long but natalie is still trying to plan
this wedding
and although that makes no sense she did
come up with a really good idea
which is to go to couples therapy mike
was against it at first but then he
agreed
so he could get some things off his
chest why are you here why are you
putting forth this effort this is a hard
situation he puts huge effort actually
so tell him that directly i told you
michael you put huge effort bringing me
this cabin visa
so thank you
for putting this effort are we still in
love
[Music]
it's difficult for me a lot
we're not in love right now you often
ask me why why i don't want to talk
about marriage in a wedding right now
we're halfway here because we're not in
love hey
if you're gonna go to therapy you have
to be ready to hear those hard truths
natalie of course didn't take mike's
comment well
she said it was unexpected and she
wished she didn't hear it
now i'm sure there are a lot of things
that mike
wishes he never heard come out of
natalie's mouth but they did
this house looks like from movia it's
like from
coromos i just hate horror movies it's
time to get
snowy and wet see that you're serious
about diet and
uh you will just i'm telling you do you
need this
yeah i need to put some of it you need
to lose some of it so
chi-ching low-class
what do you know about low class i live
in it now
you can only talk down to someone for so
long
until they realize that this is not love
first steps it meant you got a problem
problem is we're not in love anymore
i don't want to make all these plans and
it's not there
then maybe we just need to come to a
conclusion that it's not there
your ideal world what happens my idea
world
oh ideal word i guess falling in love
and uh getting married
i think that's about it thank you very
much walking some kids
uh raising a family enjoying life
is that with natalie
don't know
[Music]
i'm done you can tell he wants out
he really does but he's just so deep in
it
that's one of the major downsides to
being in a long-term relationship
even when you know you don't want that
person anymore
it can be so hard to end it so
hard but based off the preview for next
week
it seems as if natalie is about to make
walking away
a bit easier it's funny because i'm much
beautiful than you
your beauty is ugly it is okay
just because you think you're the most
hottest in the world
doesn't make you a great person inside
but but i'm looking at
me i don't cheat you you cheat and you
lie
when does natalie go back to ukraine
seriously
that's a lot of stress for anybody to
deal with consistently
hopefully in real time these two have
found peace
individually alright alright
90 day fans fam so make sure you stay
updated on all the latest news coming
out the 90 day universe
make sure you stick with et because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you